hey there I'm Jonathan LaValle professor
of marketing at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business as you may have
guessed from the title of this video
throughout our marketing mini series I'm
gonna review concepts to help you
identify new marketing opportunities so
what is marketing many people hear the
word marketing and think it's a synonym
for advertising or sales but ads in
sales are just one tactical component of
the marketing process what marketing
really is is the process of determining
the needs and wants of customers and
delivering the desired benefits more
effectively and efficiently than
competitors in order to achieve
organizational goals
you see marketing in action everyday
products and services you love ads on
the television or the web promotions end
of aisle displays and grocery stores
promo emails mailings targeted ads
marketing is everywhere you might be
staring right at marketing and not even
know it like for example this video it's
part of a marketing effort for our
innovation certificate program here at
Stanford out there in the world you
might see the stickers used to identify
uber or lyft drivers smell fragrances
and stores hear music and malls note the
chill vibe of a retail space or coffee
shop find store brands stock near
national brands experienced stores that
don't even sell you anything these are
all actually examples of marketing
marketing is at the heart of a new
product launch for one simple reason
successful products meet consumer needs
and they do it better than the
competition marketing is the crucial
function in a firm that enables us to
determine and understand what consumers
need there is no launching a product
without marketing period so join us in
this mini series to learn new tips and
examples of how companies like YouTube
and ways and even individuals like Snoop
Dogg use marketing successfully